angelina jolie is trading in her
maleficent horns for some elephant ears
in the new disney plus film the one and
only ivan
now during this shutdown this hollywood
mom is actually finding the silver
lining
and having all six of her kids under one
roof
i'm so lucky we've all been used to
being tight together
for a long time and it was so nice when
matt
came home from college now he's going to
be going to college in korea while he's
still in the house
when you have that many children they
really take care of each other they help
me
i'm not alone managing everything they
are an amazing team
so i'm very very fortunate it was
actually one of her team members who's
responsible for angie taking on this
beloved children's book turned movie
role
well shiloh years ago told me that she'd
read a book that she loved and she
wanted me to read it
i read it on my own and then we looked
at some of it together and we talked
about why she loved it
and then i inquired if it was being made
as you do into a film
so i tried to stay with it and push it
to stay as true to the book as possible
memories never leave us they just get
out of reach
angie is a producer and voices an
african elephant in the one and only
ivan the true story of a silverback
gorilla in a circus mall who begins to
paint
sam rockwell voices ivan he was
basically imprisoned by this concrete
cage in in a mall and it's a it's an
amazing story that he really did these
watercolor paintings you know
all-star ensemble provides the voices
but unlike most animated films
they got to record together can you tell
what this is uh
a cheeto it's a key you can improvise
you can laugh at each other because
you know sam and danny were always
making me laugh you've got to love him
first day i didn't know that you know so
i didn't wear pants the first day either
afterwards i could i couldn't get up i
could
he was a mess you hit the nail right are
you wearing pants right now danny
i just have a shirt on angie dressed
down too that idea came from her young
co-star brooklyn prince
you're not terrifying i said hey
why don't we wear elephant onesies and
she was like
sure on the day she shows up she pulls
on her elephant onesie and we took a
selfie
and we rocked them the rest of the day
but it got hot so we just tied them
around our waist
ryan cranston actually had to wear
clothes he plays the circus owner
let's give him a great show okay there's
a lot of themes in this movie the
importance of finding your people
you want supportive people around you
and are not judging you or but
but are there to catch you when you're
at your weakest